[Music]
welcome to the stanford mba admissions
session on preparing for a career in
consulting my name is lisa jananjali i'm
a director of mba admissions at the
stanford graduate school of business as
well as an alumna of the program
and i am super excited to host this
panel today because both before and
after business school
i was a consultant but today i'm joined
by some of my fellow
gsb alumni who are currently working in
the consulting industry and they will
share some of their perspectives with
you
so just a little bit about what to
expect from today's
event really the whole purpose of
today's event is to allow you an
opportunity to engage with our community
to learn a little bit more about the gsb
experience and how it can really help
enable
your future aspirations so we'll talk a
little bit about where this journey can
take you
you'll have an opportunity to meet our
panelists i'll start us off with some
q a some questions there that we have
prepared and really we want to spend the
majority of time
answering your questions so at any point
in today's session please feel free to
go to that q a box and pop in a question
that you would like to ask our panelists
we'll try to get to as many questions as
we can if you see a question that
someone else has asked that you
particularly like
just click on that thumbs up symbol and
that will vote that question up towards
the top
so let's get started let's start with
where will your journey
take you now with the stanford mba i
think the possibilities are
endless but here you see a few
high-level stats for one of our recent
graduating classes so for the class of
2020
91 of our students had job offers um
three months after graduation
there were 445 different organizations
that were recruiting our mba students
and 71 of our mba students made a career
pivot
whether that was an industry function
location
or some combination of those three
as you can see year in year out
consulting remains one of the top five
industries and functional areas that our
graduates go into
we're very proud that for several years
now we have had record compensation
within the mba marketplace
for the class of 2020 those who are
graduating the median base salary was
156
000 that year and if you look at those
graduates who went into consulting the
median base salary was even higher at
165 000
per year but let's spend a little bit of
time
i'm talking to some of these consultants
and meeting some of
our alumni so we have a wonderful group
who is joining us today
some who were working in consulting
before business school and really used
this experience to
accelerate their careers and others who
perhaps were looking to pivot
into consulting and use the gsb
experience as a way to do
that um so i'll have each of the
panelists briefly introduce yourselves
we'll go in order that we see
here and ryan we'll have you start
please
thanks lisa hello everyone um i
graduated
just be class of 2020 so it was
interesting to see those statistics that
lisa was just sharing about my class
um before the gsb i'll start just
undergrad went to american university
studying international studies i stayed
in washington dc
doing strategy and management consulting
at deloitte
then after the gsb i moved to new york
where i've had a focus on design and
innovation consulting still at deloitte
and focusing on healthcare
great thank you ryan hi everyone my name
is rachel
i'm originally from sacramento
california and i went to duke university
for undergrad where i studied public
policy
after graduating i spent five years in
chicago i worked in consumer packaged
goods doing
brand management and then went to
stanford for
my mba i interned in consulting and then
accepted full-time position
with bain afterwards i've been there for
about two years and in my time so far i
focus on our private equity group
as well as utilities thanks
hi everyone i'm monday i graduated with
rachel in 2019
um started i was a biotechnology
engineer in
undergrad in mexico so started off my
career
in more like research in the medical
space and then pivoted into
consulting right before the gsb i was
part of the
makenzin nairobi office in kenya
focusing on
social sector consulting especially and
used kind of the dsb
experience to continue that track now
that i returned to mckinsey two years
ago
so it's great to be here
awesome thanks andrea um hey everybody
my name is jonathan
um graduated from the gsb in 2016.
um coming out of undergrad at yale i
spent most of my time
in the cleantech and clean energy space
so i developed renewable energy projects
for about two years and then spent about
two two and a half years
developing a lot of the operational
processes to manage the electrical grid
given
renewables coming online um at mckinsey
so post business school um i shifted to
consulting after business school so at
mckinsey i focused on a lot of the same
topics that i did
beforehand but just in consulting so i
work primarily with utility clients
clean energy clean tech and a lot on
sustainability
as well
hey good evening i'm scott i'm from san
diego california
before the gsb i worked in healthcare i
worked for a healthcare nonprofit in san
diego did a mixture of
commercializing innovative healthcare
technologies worked in
tele obstetrics and tele orthopedics as
well as doing some lobbying it was
during the the passage of the affordable
care act i also worked in healthcare
policy
um at the gsb was looking for a way to
you know blend
my interest in industry with my interest
in policy ended up
pursuing public sector consulting i'm
now at bcg
and i've worked on a variety of
different public sector projects
hi all this is casey i went to stanford
as an undergrad and then came back for
my mba
graduated uh gosh more than 10 years ago
now which is unbelievable to me
uh but definitely used my time at this
at stanford to to
do a few pivots so i had worked in
financial services
for visa prior to coming to stanford and
it actually been the client
uh with a consulting firm working on the
other side and realized that that was
what i thought would be a more exciting
you know path and so i
came to the gsb and uh found out that
there was this company called bain that
got me really excited and
i used it as an opportunity to both
pivot into consulting but also
um have been with our healthcare
practice for most of the last decade
and that's where i spend the majority of
my time uh including the last year and a
half have been working with a coveted
testing provider so you can imagine how
exciting this uh
these last 12 months have been so
looking forward to talking with you more
well thank you all for the uh the
introductions maybe before we dive into
consulting specifically just a
higher level broad question that some of
you might want to answer
why did you decide to do an mba and why
specifically
at stanford so
for me coming from being in consulting
and then
really starting before that i called out
my undergrad
studies because i had no business
backing
um in consulting and in several
industries
they bring in a multi-disciplinary
approach and so they're looking for
those that have different backgrounds
but it meant that
my business core
function focus analysis
needed to be beefed up that's kind of
one of the reasons i then started
looking at mbas in general and then for
me in particular
stanford and the gsb that are really the
home
to what we call design thinking starting
from the customer viewpoint
what our customer needs motivations
frustrations and
using that as inspiration for innovation
tying that into
new business models we're in the heart
of silicon valley so
different ways of engaging with
customers that all then
attracted me to the gsb and as i learned
more it became the community that i saw
among students
that then really excited me and said
this is the place i want to get my mba
from
so it was kind of a ladder of different
things coming down the bike
i actually tried really hard to not come
back to stanford having been an
undergrad i was like all right i've
already done that that was amazing
but i should really go somewhere else um
but when
i decided i wanted to make the decision
on the merits of the school
and stanford was just tied to shoulders
above all the other
options um especially for me what really
stood out was
um classes that were focused on
leadership development
you know really thinking about not just
how to develop like a true general
manager mindset
but really honing that with leadership
skills touchy-feely organizational
design like
the things that i was starting to
realize in my career pre-mba
were really making the difference
between people who were just okay at
their jobs and the ones who really
excelled
and to me stanford was just head and
shoulders above above all the other
options on that dimension
great let me chime in with another
question here so i know
um some of you were pivoting into
consulting after your gsb
experience for those of you who made
that pivot how did the gsb
help you with that transition whether it
was from you know academic coursework or
career support or clubs alumni students
you know how did how did gsb enable that
transition into consulting
i can speak here um so as i mentioned i
worked in consumer package
packaged goods before business school
but knew i wanted
to do a summer internship in consulting
and stanford had a lot of resources
um you know you get a little taste of it
with some of the academic work
i would say the clubs are great but to
me the biggest resource was actually my
fellow students
stanford students are probably the most
giving
and thoughtful students in the world and
i just
reached out to all of my classmates who
were former consultants
to do um case prep and they all gave me
so much time like
i can't even tell you how much time we
spend in the library just going through
different cases
and i think that was actually probably
the most valuable resource that i had at
stanford with my fellow students
for um jonathan or others who also made
that transition into consulting how do
you think the gsb experience helped you
enable that yeah so lisa i think on
on my part you know i think similar
story you know i was working at a
utility just before coming to business
school and
lots of folks that were you know very
very good at their jobs but maybe not
the most motivated to try and go do new
things and so one of the things i wanted
to do coming into the gsp
was kind of figuring out how to work
with and motivate others
to do really um amazing things and so
for me the gsb's uh arbuckle leadership
program was
uh really wonderful i so i did that my
second year
at the gsp uh and then that's been
really helpful for me
in consulting because a lot of our
day-to-day work is around
how do you influence and inspire clients
to go further and kind of push further
beyond their boundaries
uh for those of you who are coming from
a consulting background
um already uh and maybe using the gsb um
to accelerate your career
what do you think you got out of this
experience that you wouldn't have
received otherwise if you had just
continued you know working through
and skipped an mba
i can jump in here um so i was looking
to
obviously a much smaller pivot but to
pivot between within consulting from
being like a generalist to them focusing
only
on public and social sector consulting
and stanford
specifically gave me an opportunity to
first to a
joint mba with an ma in education within
the two years which is very important to
me
and also within the gsb was able to
align especially to the social
innovation
kind of side of the the classes that we
were able to take
and that really kind of gave me another
perspective focusing on
emerging markets and a little bit of
more of the social pieces that i was
trying to develop
so it definitely prepared me to then
come back to mckinsey
in a more like expert specialized role
than i would have been able to do
um without taking the time to to go back
to school
again
all right um pivoting again i know
consulting might be
new for a lot of the people who are
tuning in today so
how would you all describe the typical
day in the life of or
week in the life of a consultant he
wants to
shed some light there what it's like to
actually work in the industry
i can i can start us off um
obviously a different story pre pre-code
than
postcode um currently what it looks like
is obviously a lot of zoom calls um and
during those there's a mix of client
calls but also
problem solving or brainstorming
depending on what term you use with your
team and colleagues but also with
internal experts or external experts to
the firm
basically what you're trying to do in
your day-to-day is solve
some sort of specific problem that
you're that your client has that is
really like top of mind and taking so
much energy from them
so you're there to kind of provide a
little bit of that surge support to
to help them get through either that
bump or to get to the next level
depending if it's a
kind of like positive or negative
situation a little bit
um and before it used to
also involve a lot of travel um might
pick up back again once you uh are like
post your your mba will probably be in
another normal
um but that has been a little bit of a
different reality for the past couple of
months
i don't know if anybody else wants to
chime in
yup how have you balanced the um the
workload and the the travel and kind of
you know normal steady state or
time at the client site versus um in
your office how does that look even
yeah i mean i'll say consulting there's
never a dull moment in consulting for
sure you wake up in the morning and
um you don't know exactly how that day
is going to unfold and
at least for me that is still 10 years
into the into the job
what gets me going i love i love that
aspect of it and then
you know i have two kids now one's four
years old and one's
two um and so we
have had to just make some real
boundaries around you know my job gets
can take a lot of my time but we have
really clear i call them the golden
hours
so when we wake up in the morning until
eight like those are my kids times i
just don't do other stuff and the same
thing at the end of the day
six to eight i just don't touch work my
laptop etc
and um it's been a really good forcing
function and really well received
you know within not just my company in
bain but
with my clients right that they actually
do respect that we're all
human and you know have families and
other obligations outside of work and
it's um
it's refreshing to be able to just have
those conversations those two humans
like hey here my boundaries are limits
um and i've found that you know there
have been times when this job has been
busier than other times
but throughout um those kinds of honest
communicative
conversations have been what have broken
through and made sure that um that it
was kind of the best of all worlds so
10 years in it's still going great i
love i love it
i think one of the great things about
consulting too is that you
there is a little there's more ability
to control
how that lifestyle might look for you
than you might get in some other
industry so
that i joined bcg with a classmate at
the gsb who convinced me that we should
apply to bcg together and we've got to
attract each other's careers all the way
through and we've taken
very different routes in terms of you
know what we're interested in but then
also
how we balance travel or how we think
about the role of the the
the um job in our lives so she's you
know
married expecting her first child you
know has a dog and optimizes for she
doesn't want to travel
she's also she's a extrovert so she
loves being in the office she loves
those big group settings
she's been able to create that setting
for herself i you know
don't you know don't live with anyone
don't have a dog
um and am an introvert so i'm able to
arrange my day around
you know the kind of things that give me
energy which is you know plenty of alone
time
you know to think through a problem and
then talk to people about it
you know i also i wanted to maximize the
travel so i lived out of a suitcase for
two years and
you know bounced around the world doing
projects it was a great adventure
and it sounded like the worst thing in
the world to her so i think one of the
great things that we're at the same firm
started in the same office
um so i think what's great is that you
have the ability to really
you know control how you want the career
to look for you
and i'll just add scott that's totally
true over the course of the career too
like
in my first years in consulting i wanted
the same thing i wanted to be traveling
all the time i went did six months in
paris i
did the whole global thing and then
what i wanted changed and the great
thing about my job was that it was able
to change with me
um and that was sort of an unexpected
benefit i don't know that i was like
solving for that when i was at the gsb
applying for consulting jobs
but it's been great
all right maybe switching gears to talk
a little bit about recruiting
um so some of you may have gone through
the recruiting process for consulting
jobs relatively recently as you were you
know
finishing up your gsb experience others
of you might actually be involved in the
recruiting process
now and helping the interview and screen
resumes and things you know within your
respective firms how could you um
shed some light on what the recruiting
process within consulting looks like
how people might best prepare for that
or come up to speed
and be successful in those those
interviews and in that recruiting
process
um i think rachel was thinking at this
when she was talking about the benefits
of the gsb
as much as you can do in terms of like
practicing cases so each firm has a
little bit of a different style of how
we do
cases but overall there's there's a case
study involved
um across all of our firms um
so taking the time to really practice
with a peer so not not only yourself
doing trying to do it and kind of like
self reflect i think that
is really really helpful um my only
small tip would be also like don't
overdo it
to a point where it sounds scripted
because there's also a little bit of a
tipping point that is
is reached at some point um but i don't
know rachel if you have
other other tips as well yeah no
i think that's the right advice um
one thing just to start with that's
really nice about the gsb
is that they actually protect um your
first i think it's maybe two
months um at school uh so
it's really nice because it like allows
you to get acquainted with being a
student again and
you really don't have to think about
recruiting and then once that does begin
i think it's great to talk to your
fellow classmates who have done
consulting figure out
you know what they really liked about
the job uh
how that you know matches what your
career ambitions are
and then spend time doing a lot of case
crap um honestly
that's like the crux of the interview is
you won't be doing cases and so
i think it's really important to figure
out you know the structure of that
but as andrea said don't overdo it don't
become too robotic
always approach it as if you know you
were actually in the job yourself
day one like what are the big questions
that you're trying to answer
and then go from there
all right we'll turn to maybe some
questions from our audience here
um so we have one that says for someone
who's looking to pivot into consulting
and maybe
doesn't have as much day-to-day insight
could you let us know
um you know what's the part of your role
that you both enjoy and what is the part
of your role in consulting that you
least
enjoy
i can start us off um and i think
as the panel is already starting to
highlight the consulting journey
for each person is so individual and you
can
tweak different dynamics of it so i
imagine my answers will be very
different than others um
the thing that i like the most about
consulting and like
that excites me each day is working in
my team
um the at least at deloitte and i i
believe so and other consulting firms
were
very team oriented and we work on a
problem together bringing different
perspectives
and that approach i feel like has
allowed me to continue to grow
every day i'm learning something new
from my teammates
it's also as i've moved up in the in
consulting
then you you play more of a manager role
and that also
comes with its own stretching of how do
i make the best environment for the team
members around me and that i think is a
really fun
challenging energizing problem
um to constantly be working through so i
think that's that's my
highlight um maybe we do highlights
around or
one other person just highlights before
we go to what's what's
more challenging in the role
i love the fact that i get to dig into
problems that excite me and i know what
excites me is going to be different from
someone else but
i just like at the gsb where i love the
fact that i got to take whatever classes
i wanted in my second year
and including across the street courses
um the same in consulting i get to
dig into you know how do state
governments set their budgets and that's
the thing that really gets me excited
everybody else might think it's a
a snoozer but you know everybody gets to
kind of find the the thing that excites
them
i really i like the fact that the
problems are there's stuff that i care
about and stuff that you know feels like
it matters and i got to pick it
any other relationships that i've been
building not just
so i get to have my bane family my
teams and my colleagues i've gotten to
know over time and worked with closely
but then
i also have my clients who at this point
i've got somebody asked in the q a like
your clients was like yeah they're my
like they're people that i've built
really deep relationships with and
i know their families i know their
aspirations i give them career advice
like it's a very deep relationship um
and i love that about consulting that
i've had the opportunity to build those
out
over time anything on the other side of
the coin oh rachel sorry you're going to
chime in
oh i mean it's similar to what other
folks have said but you know the
problems that we're facing are problems
that are challenging enough that you
know the clients are like okay we need
someone else to come in and help and to
me
that's really motivating and really
exciting
um it's also you know you're really
focused on cracking this one problem
i remember when i was working in cpg
before
business school i felt like you know
there were a ton of things on my plate
my attention constantly got drawn to
different places
and it didn't allow me to like really
like focus on
some of the biggest issues that i really
wanted to tackle and i love that i get
to be really
dedicated to that in this role um and
like everyone said too i really like how
we have this
case team environment where everyone's
really in it together
and the collaboration with the client is
really inspiring as well so
there's a lot of elements of this job
that are really fantastic
jonathan did you have anything you
wanted to add or do you want to go to
the dark side
i mean i think it's it's been said but i
think the people element
as well like many of the same folks that
you'd be going to business school with
you know
developed great relationships will be on
your consulting teams
or they'll be the ones that are your
peers when you're in the office on
fridays or
during covet maybe every day but when
you're in the office on fridays
they'll be the ones that you're hanging
out with and um it's not something that
you'll
you'll probably see in any other job
how about some of the the downsides or
some of the things that you're at least
excited about within the consulting
industry
just to be fair and look at the other
side of the coin
since i started this with positive i can
i can start on the other side too um
which for me i think as i am
thinking about consulting versus what's
next
one of the things i've i've felt in
consulting is
we we have a as rachel was talking like
dedicated on one core
problem altogether but then we
understandably hand it off for uh an
implementation to happen or for
further thinking to happen or for it to
be embedded in the organization
but i often then don't don't see the
the reach the customer side of it so if
we're thinking
upstream i have a lot of focus there
i i'm i'm wondering for me the next
question i'm dealing with in my own
career is
what does that look like downstream how
do i like that the implementation part
the owning something start to finish
um we're owning start to finish the
answer to some problems
but thinking about in the full life
cycle of an organization
and thinking about the organizational
beyond that and so
a lot of the classes of the gsb have
exposed me to that level of thinking
that i'm
now curious about which i have less
insight into
and that would be i think one of my
challenges with consulting for right now
i think the the other thing that we're
all like tiptoeing around like
it's long hours it's part of the
industry
i think across the sector is just how
consulting has been set up it has been
improving and hopefully it keeps on
improving
um but it is it is a demanding job
because of what everybody has said of
we're solving problems that we're
we brought in because somebody else
couldn't solve them so therefore
it's uh it's usually like a big
ask
i will say though i know i'm at a point
where i think my clients work harder
than i do so just
there is a there's a time out there
where
and i definitely get to take sabbaticals
and time off
because of the project-based work a
little bit more easily than i think some
of my clients who are in
in industry so there's a shining light
out there
um i would also say just you know there
is a period of time when people like
okay so you're doing consulting for now
but like what's your real career going
to be
um and i would just say like as scott
and ryan and others have said like
lots of different ways that you enter
and sometimes exit consulting but
um i you know have times have had to say
like no
i really enjoy consulting this is my
career like um and there's an identity
there and a path there and there's a lot
of joy and fulfillment there so you know
sometimes that's a big question that
people have that you
end up fielding a lot
all right we have another question here
from our audience um given the location
of stanford right there in the heart of
silicon valley and
this hot bed of innovation and all sorts
of different things going on
what swayed you to consulting or helped
you to stay the course in consulting if
you were already in it
versus maybe moving to private equity or
venture capital or technology or
something else
how did the the location kind of impact
your experience and maybe
make you even more excited about
consulting or expose you to different
things that help you now
um i think it goes off and i think this
is also very depending on
like class by class every class has a
little bit of a a different vibe to it
my personal experience uh
with like stanford in consulting was it
wasn't
especially in during the first year it
was not the highest let's say
ranked preference that i would say like
oh what did you do before coming to
stanford and minus ruby i was in
mckinsey
and the answer was usually like oh kind
of
because people are much more excited
about the i
started it like you know i did a startup
or i was doing this like
weird thing in the middle of nowhere and
stuff like that
and that was much more like energizing
and attention grabbing
especially in the first couple months
once we started getting closer to summer
internships that quickly
shifted but to
the the implied question of like was it
easy to say
the the course uh for me it wasn't like
i definitely felt a little bit more the
pressure of
expanding and like looking again and
rethinking everything what is out there
um in the end i didn't find something
that was
as exciting to me as uh continuing down
the consulting
path like to what casey was saying of
like that being my career so i decided
to
stay um but it was definitely the
signaling around it
is definitely on like expand explore
search like do
new and different things so um there it
was a little bit of going against that
yeah
i think the um i did not come to the gsb
thinking i was going to be a consultant
when i left and even
probably right up to about a month
before graduation i didn't think i would
be a consultant when i left
uh tried a lot of different things i
think stanford's location
meant that i had the ability to try a
lot of different things and to try them
seriously so i worked for a venture fund
we founded a social enterprise in nepal
you know i worked for local government
like i tried a lot of different things
in addition to trying consulting and i
think that
the location of the stanford network
gave me the data that i needed to be
able to say
okay i've you know i i thought all these
things could be interested i tried all
of them now i have the information
i need to know that consulting was the
right thing for me but it
certainly wasn't you know didn't didn't
come with that mission but stanford is a
place that encourages experimentation i
love
i don't know if it's the same approach
but i love the you know the career
counseling process they're very much
said you know don't go reconfirm things
you already know try things you don't
know about to try to get the information
about
what you do you don't like and and what
works for you and i'm really glad i
ended up in consulting and i'm also
really glad that
silicon valley meant that it was really
easy to try a bunch of other things
um in parallel
go ahead just to add to that too um
about stanford providing the
opportunities to test waters in a lot of
spaces i think that's absolutely true
and because of its location you get you
know ceos of high-tech companies coming
in to talk to you
and also coursework if anyone's
interested in creating
uh their own company their startup
garage and i had a couple of friends
go through startup garage and most of
them realize you know what i don't think
i'm gonna be a founder
and went on to find jobs at other
companies um
for me one thing that was um
i don't know kind of won me over for
consulting is kind of what rhino alluded
to too
is you can start consulting but still
pivot into another industry afterwards
i really feel like there isn't really a
downside of starting in consulting
unless you know exactly what you want to
do and it's not consulting
it gives you a really good opportunity
to explore and grow a lot
um and the skills that you will gain
from consulting similar to stanford
will help you in whatever career that
you want to do afterwards if you decide
eventually
you do want to be you know industry or
role
focused so
all right we have another question here
are there any must
take um courses or experiences that
really helped you build your strategic
thinking or leadership skills for
consulting
i can take that on lisa i mean i don't
think that there were any in particular
that were
um must takes i would say that there's
probably two that are just general
gsb must takes that i would recommend um
so touchy feely which is also known as
interpersonal dynamics which is a great
class will help you
one just generally in all of your
relationships but probably also help you
relate to your to your clients
as well in consulting and then the other
one that was
i found to be incredibly helpful was
managing growing enterprises which just
helped you
have and role play a lot of difficult
conversations that you might have
with clients or with some folks on your
team as well
certainly other classes maybe that are
that are helpful but you know
i think for all of the firms that are
represented here there's a fair amount
of
onboarding and training in terms of hard
skills so
um i'd probably focus a bit more on the
interpersonal
soft stuff while you're at the gsb i
just have to say i'm relieved to hear
that the two classes i was going to say
are still being told by fbas who
graduated more recently that makes me
feel warm and fuzzy and not so old
so that's very cool two thumbs up for
mge and interpersonal dynamics
and then i would i would just emphasize
that part about like uh because i saw a
few questions in in the chat about um
non-profit backgrounds or less
traditional backgrounds like
we are absolutely kind of i think all
the firms are focused on making sure
that the hard skills you need like how
to do
a p l or how to use excel like you're
going to get those skills
on the job like the training is
excellent in consulting so
the time of the gsb is precious for a
lot of the
more gm oriented touchy-feely uh types
of classes i think
any other classes or or experiences that
that
you draw upon today anyone else
in general i just think just take the
risk when you're
at the gsb so because of grade
non-disclosure and because the fa
the fact that the student body is
incredibly supportive of each other
like take the harder version of the
course if you're on the fence between
the base level and the harder level of
marketing like take the take the
advanced course or
if you're not certain about that across
the street court like
take take the risk it's an incredibly
safe environment
i think that the the times when i push
myself harder into those like more
advanced courses or
i took the you know uh international
policy course across the street that i
had no business being in were the ones
that one's where i actually learned the
most
any other favorites
i can build on that too i mean i think
one thing that's great about stanford is
like yes you do have
classes that are set up with like the
typical like case structure
but you have a lot of different formats
too and some of the other formats is
what i loved
a lot i took a class my second year
called leadership perspectives
where we just brought in really
inspiring leaders from different
industries
to tell us about their career journey
and how they thought about
their leadership style over the course
of it and at the end i had the
opportunity to sit down and reflect
what kind of leader do i want to be
tomorrow in five years in ten years
and to me that's like a really great
opportunity
um i also kind of like mge as
uh jonathan said there's a class called
managing a difficult conversations and
it's all about role-playing
and sometimes you don't realize how uh
much
you learn from actually just trying to
do it yourself it's different to think
something to actually try
speaking it and i love those classes at
stanford
and then lastly there's a lot of design
oriented classes
um ryan i think you had mentioned that
earlier i took a class called equity by
design
and i've actually directly used some of
the principles i learned in that class
and the diversity equity inclusion
allyship work i do at vayne
so um yeah stanford offers
uh very different formats or a lot of
very different formats and they're all
really really valuable
i'm curious if any of you were involved
in the consulting club during your time
on campus and if so how was that
experience and in addition to the
consulting club what were some other
helpful um resources that helped you
um with the recruiting i know you
mentioned classmates
and such earlier but are there any other
things at a consulting club or other
resources
i feel like the alumni network deserves
a mention as well you know i
wanted to move geographies as part of
recruiting for consulting so you know
called up the alumni
in australia and said you know i'm
interested in making
making a move to australia um you know
can you can you help me through this
process i think that was
absolutely invaluable it's also great to
be able to talk to
you know alumni from multiple firms to
be able to you know get a sense for how
how the different firms operated so
beyond the
the people that are on campus there to
help you and your peers
you know the people who are part of the
broader community i found absolutely
invaluable throughout the process
does any of you um rely on career
management advisors or career management
support during your time
there as you were making this transition
or deciding if you wanted to stay in
consulting or not or
i i ended up using the cmc is what it's
called uh
at the gsb and more i'll call it more of
like a therapy session around
my career progression and where i wanted
to go
um which great some great listeners
um of just like helping me verbalize out
loud
where i wanted to track my career in the
short term and in the longer term and
then what what that meant actually for
my gsb
experience so kind of taking it full
circle
um i found them helpful in thinking
through that and then i also went to
i'd say what the because we're
all central on uh stanford's campus and
the gsp is like tucked in
in a corner i used that what we call mba
twos when i was in nba one so my
when i was the first year the second
years to kind of bounce ideas back
and forth as well so it was like if we
think of lots of different
levels of people to engage um i also
found them
useful you're surrounded by so many
people all thinking about those same
questions
we've talked a little bit about some of
the the resources that folks have used
um as they were thinking about the
consulting industry
there's a question here of you know if
if consulting
really is a focus at the gsb or not um
andre i think you kind of maybe
highlighted that a little bit
um you're you know when you first
arrived and how that shifted over your
time there as it got closer to summer
internships and such
uh but did you feel that the school
tried to either push you
towards or push you away from consulting
is
sort of the gist of this question did
you
um i didn't i didn't feel that the the
school or the classes
the teachers themselves try to push me
towards or away from consulting or
towards or away from
any other career i think a lot of the
conversation
was focused on just like more the the
concept of a leader that i think
rachel was mentioning of like what type
of leader do you want to be
uh obviously like aligned with the the
schools like ethos as well
like what type of change do you want to
drive what good do you want to bring to
the world etc
so that piece there was a lot of focus
on reflecting on that and
learning the skills to build towards
that um but i don't think at any point
there was like a
kind of industry push um
some of the classes i feel like do
assume a little bit of a private sector
more like focus but there's other also
um
where i leaned on more of like social
innovation and all that track um
and a lot of the classes were like okay
if you were this if you were the ceo of
this what would you do
so there is an assumption of like that
type of career
um but not in a specific industry would
be my
my personal experience
all right i see a question here um
obviously there are a lot of different
wonderful consulting firms out there you
work for many of them
there are also different um types of
consulting even you know within
various firms too um how did you find
the right
fit for you both the company and the
type of work that you're doing within
that company and
um are there different personality types
by firm or capabilities that firms are
looking for
kind of a little bit more about that fit
in finding your place
i'll i'll take a stab at this one
although it's a interesting one
um so i i think once upon a time we were
all
recruiting for consulting and um
we're all kind of randomly picking which
ones we like and we've all got our own
different personalities and i don't know
that any of the firms are necessarily
looking for
different personalities but i do think
the firms will have different
personalities that resonate
better with you and i think that during
the
recruiting process you will find um
just what works better for you that
could both be the firm's actual culture
or it could also
be who in particular from the firm shows
up for that particular
cultivation event so it's a little bit
of learning
on your part but i certainly know that
you know mckinsey is not
out there looking for a specific
personality and in fact we're actually
looking to have
um be as inclusive and look for as many
different types of
folks as possible so we can get as many
uh different voices
as we make uh decisions and make sure
that we're representing
um our clients and our clients customers
as best we can in these rooms where
we're making recommendations to them
can i ask um just even from you know
within your firms trying to figure out
do you want to be more of a generalist
or have a particular industry focus or
other area of expertise you know how did
you navigate that or how much time do
you have to decide or things like that
that might be helpful for our audience
um again i mean i think on that one um
it's probably a little bit up to you so
you know i think for all of our firms
there's probably generalists and maybe
you know certainly mckinsey there are
folks that are expert focused so
they may focus on a specific function or
industry
um or particular growth area and so
um you know i know that mckinsey is
really excited and has this thing
you know where you can kind of do
whatever you want to some extent
they call it make your own mckinsey um
but basically if you are most
excited about um doing clean technology
work or sustainability work
um like like i was you know you can you
can focus on that
either by being a generalist or being
exclusively an expert
on that topic and so um to some extent
it really just comes down to
what you want to do and then trying to
find uh the right people at
mckinsey at least and i don't know how
it works at the other firms that are
represented here
um you can try and make that that
particular
uh approach work um but you really need
to have some some conversations with
different folks to
to create some of those opportunities i
will say consultants are really good at
alliteration
so you've got make your own mckinsey and
we have build your own bane but it's the
same idea
in consulting which is um you over time
can start to shape it but you don't come
in at least into being you do not come
in having to wear one hat and not
another and
you'll actually get an opportunity to
wear a lot of different hats and see
which industries do you enjoy the most
what type of work do you end up enjoying
the most and
by now i probably have three or four
different hats that i interchange i'm
like
a healthcare expert i'm an
organizational change
expert you know there's like a few
different hats that i can wear depending
on the context but those were built
over time and because that was what i
ended up enjoying doing
um but i didn't go in saying that's what
i'm going to go do so
to some extent when you start you can't
know what the answer for you is going to
be i mean i
i came in laser focused i wanted to do
economic development public sector
consulting that's what i wanted to do
and thankfully i really clicked with the
people
at bcg who do that sort of work but i've
also had a lot of my colleagues who
joined out of the gsb
uh come and like not have any interest
in retail but
really clicked and had strong
relationships with a client in retail or
with
you know what a managing director in
retail and you know they've now become
partners in the retail practice at bcg
so it's
so much of it's going to be driven by
you know the choice that you want to
make and the stuff that excites you and
what you're passionate about
but it's also going to be about the
people that you meet and where you where
you build those relationships because
as everybody said earlier on in the end
this is a it's a team sport it's a
people business and it's going to be
about
you know where are you going to who are
you going to want to work with over
over the longer term or you know when we
eventually get back to travel the cliche
of
you know who are you going to want to be
stuck in an airport with uh when your
flight gets delayed and that you know
that day-to-day experience is
is really i think what makes it for a
lot of people
here's a great question um can you speak
to maybe a moment
that you knew you made the right
decision to come to the gsb
um it could be a particular moment a
class an interaction a lecture
uh whatever it might be what was that
moment for you
for for me um something near and dear to
my heart
from the gsb is a program we call talk
um where two students
each week from each class uh go up in
front of their
their classmates and share life-defining
moments
things that inspire them why they are
the way they are
could be the gsb essay what matters most
um
and i know i gave my personal talk
um january of my first year so
we had a couple months under our belts
but we're still settling in
and that feeling afterwards was
is something that i will stick with me
forever um
the incredible support of peers
even some of them were nascent friends
some of them were still strangers
um but that feeling of support of like
being held by a room of 200 of your
classmates just because you've shared
about yourself um and gone to the gsb
a currency and it is around
vulnerability and um
that's shared throughout the entire
school throughout
the way that we create we've talked
about touchy-feely the way we
create relationships etc that that that
moment
at the end of my talk was something i
wish i could bottle up that i knew in
that moment
i was in the right place for me at the
right time
for me and that it's more personal than
professional but i think has tied into
how i create professional relationships
with clients
across teams etc
anyone else want to share a moment when
they they knew they'd made the right
decision
i can go um i think i knew it
from the moment i stepped on campus on
my first day
um and there were so many moments during
the course of the two years but i'll
share a personal one
that's a recess it's not the first
moment but it's a recent moment is uh
i'm planning my wedding and as you do
that you think about who you're
going to invite right and a majority of
my best friends in life
are now the people who i met at stanford
and i cannot tell you
how much like they mean to me and um
you know it it doesn't always happen uh
but the people at stanford are really
like the best people i personally have
met in my life and uh
i can't imagine not having the
experience now so
any other moments classes interactions
um another one i can throw out there as
well
um i agree like i would second talk of
course
um and then others would be throughout
the journey in the arbuckle leadership
program that i think
jonathan maybe had mentioned as well um
and just overall echoing the talk piece
i think stanford is just like very good
at dealing with like
emotions uh in a way they asked me to
participate in a
role play in front of classmates
that were being trained to be coaches
basically
and during that role play i was a
coachee and they started nudging me into
like
topics of identity and race and a ton of
like things that ended up like crying in
front of everybody and the fact that
it was fine like it was it was not a
surprise it was almost like and
whatever i mentioned of like the room
kind of like holds you
in a way i think that was like my my
moment of
oh like it i i kind of fit here like
this is
this is a a good place to be right now
we um we tragically lost three
classmates from my class at stanford
and um i i hesitate to share that
because it's a really sad moment but
honestly like the way the community came
around
and and just it just instantly bonded us
like it happened in the first few weeks
of school and so
um that just sticks out to me because
there was that moment where we all
looked each other and we're like
we're gonna help each other get through
this incredibly difficult time and from
people in my class and also the way the
school handled it it was like an
immediate moment of like
wow i'm in the exact right place um so
grateful to this day for how the school
handled it and the people around me
a lot of very moving examples
um well i want to be cognizant of the
time i know we are coming up towards the
um
end of our session today
i want to um thank our panelists for
sharing your perspectives today
and for all of our attendees i want to
thank you for your attention
as well and your interest in stanford we
hope that this is just the start of your
stanford gsb journey
there are many ways to continue that and
one that i'd highly recommend
is a site called mystanford.mba if you
haven't been there
already definitely check that out
there's an opportunity to create a
personalized dashboard
there you can track your application
progress it'll
tee up courses or club recommendations
that might be of interest to you
or students or alumni who might have
similar interests or profiles
and it's also just another wonderful way
to find out about other events
such as the one today so again thank you
everyone for attending
uh we will have another poll question
that is popping up too
and we appreciate your responses on that
thanks to our attendees
and our panelists wish you all the best
and good luck
on your journey into a career in
[Music]
consulting